so some of you may have heard of this
wildly popular soccer obsessed 17 year
old YouTuber named I show speed he's
basically the biggest broadcaster on the
platform and has amassed over 13 million
Subs streaming everything from FIFA to
Talking Ben to
Omegle now he's no stranger to
controversy but recently he found
himself in some very hot water for
checking what seems to be the final box
when it comes to being super rich and on
YouTube
Hawking crypto
all right so if you are like me and you
had no idea who this kid was until like
two days ago here is the long and the
short of it I show speed is a
sophomore-aged content creator from
Cincinnati who started uploading Sports
gaming related YouTube videos back in
2017. he gradually Rose to prominence as
a talented NBA 2K player and eventually
started uploading a sea of IRL stuff
from that point on things went sort of
nuclear alongside his gaming streams and
super candid cell phone recorded IRL
uploads he started putting out music
videos for tracks he'd cut and by about
Midway through 2021 his channel had
started to go insane within no time he
was streaming anything and everything to
a record-breaking number of viewers it
is hard to overstate just how meteor
speeds rise actually was he got really
big really fast
unfortunately the bigger he became the
more embroiled in controversy he became
now some of these were the usual
pitfalls of being a massive streamer
such as being swatted although the
subsequent handcuffing and placing of
speed in the back of a police car
Disturbed a lot of people and of course
there was the time he set off a [__]
firework in his own bedroom
oh [__]
that said not all of his dust ups were
as silly stupid or innocent most notably
perhaps was the ban from all Riot games
he received earlier this year after
making a series of misogynistic comments
whilst streaming valorent we actually
made a video all about it which you are
free to check out of course his
popularity hardly wavered and in
addition to getting even bigger on
YouTube he's hung out with Lil Nas X
participated in a huge charity match and
become something of a Mimi fixture in
the football Community for his obsession
with Cristiano Ronaldo and regular
mispronunciation of famous players and
teams turkey
in fact it was that very clout and
Obsession that netted speed a chance to
meet some of the Sky Sports hosts in
England during their coverage of a
Manchester United game the vods of which
were wiped from Sky sports's website
earlier this week after they were made
aware of speeds aforementioned misogyny
and then to make matters even worse
couple of days later he hosted a live
stream on his YouTube channel that was
simply entitled surprise it featured
speed a Cristiano Ronaldo looked like
and a boatload of signed ps5s and
merchandise advertising some stupid open
world blockchain game thing called
Paradox meta dot IO which the
spokesperson on speeds stream assured
his audience was bound to become the
biggest crypto coin in the world
tomorrow morning
Paradox Miller underscore IO we're going
to be launching the biggest crypto coins
suffice it to say this did not go over
well with speed's Community everyone in
the chat was reportedly spamming
comments accusing speed of engaging in a
full-blown crypto pump and dump which is
well against by the Sea of copypastas
that sit beneath the archived VOD
needless to say speed wasn't exactly
thrilled about his chat becoming
downright ungovernable that is crazy bro
like dumb comments like that bro it's
making me like that's crazy bro the fact
I ever made it I said the fact that yeah
I just think like that it's just crazy
I hate that bro you're so weird bro he's
like no they're not using me dummies I'm
using you if I don't know your boat if
out of your boat mods do something cause
I'm really getting pissed off bro mods
do something bro real [__] bro and
neither were the crypto Bros on his
stream who apparently thought they were
muted while whining about the profoundly
negative response they were facing
oh my God in the wake of the absolute
rinsing he received across the internet
speed quickly released an apology in a
now deleted tweet before issuing an
on-camera apology on a subsequent
broadcast the situation is still
unfolding of course with coffeezilla
even going to the trouble of
interviewing these Paradox dudes and
confronting them head-on about the
alleged scam that is their hyper
realistic play to earn open world
cyberpunk we have at home metaverse
thing uh they also have Paris swap where
the average user can expect to earn up
to 20 percent on staking rewards all
right now if all of that sounds dumb you
can even get your friends to invest too
with with Paradox affiliate and
thankfully they behaved with exactly the
kind of level-headedness you'd expect
from a couple of crypto-obsessed
kumquats please get knowledgeable about
what happens in the crypto space so much
of the crypto space is a scam
oh God
we gotcha gotcha we got you buddy you're
a Bitcoin hater in terms of what happens
next who's to say as Hassan observed
elsewhere in his reaction video speed's
audience is probably a little too young
to feel any amount of actual substantial
resentment over this kind of betrayal or
even to classify it as a trail at all
but they're definitely pissed as for
what comes of it that is if anything
does come of it we'll let you know
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit us up on our Twitter Instagram
Facebook and tick tock